Speaker 1: Candace Owens wants to bring back a
form of eugenics where you breed children to be
better at math, the way you might breed a dog,
to be more or less aggressive or have different
coloring on its fur. This is absolutely and
utterly insane stuff. Is it Nazi stuff? Is
it? I mean, you tell me. Here is Candace Owens
explaining the South Koreans are breeding for
math skills. We should have a breeding program.
Speaker 4: So, yes, it is correct to say that
these dogs are or bred to fight. They were bred
to attack and they were bred to kill over many,
many years. And the question of whether or not
breeding works, of course it does. The question
of whether or not Darwinism is real. Of course
it is. You can breed for height, you can breed
for intelligence, you can breed for stupid.
Speaker 1: If there's something about the
use of the word breeding that is
like extremely icky, I really.
Speaker 4: Want to write. Obviously this can
take place. You can breed for athleticism. We see
examples of this all the time, but it's important
to note that just because you are bred in one way
or the other does not mean that you are locked
into that permanent state. Right? So right now,
the most mathematically capable people in the
world are Koreans. It doesn't mean that Koreans
are forever going to be the most mathematically
capable people in the world. We can start breeding
Americans, do better at math, and start doing
what they do over in Korea. Or we could not.
Speaker 1: You mean having education that works?
Speaker 4: And we can remain probably the dumbest
mathematical country in the world.
Speaker 1: Okay. So the I don't know
that the funny is the right word, but the
ironic thing here is Candice has almost got
it. She's she's almost got it. You don't have
to breed children for math. Just educate them.
Educate the people that we have. Now, why wait
to have a multi-generational breeding program
for math? Educate people now? We could better
fund education, which she's against. Many of
her cohort want to eliminate the Department
of Energy. Many of her cohort want to teach
creationism in science class. Along the theory of
evolution. They are doing the dumbing down. They
want to get rid of a whole bunch of books. They
want to require things, be in the curriculum that
aren't going to make anybody better at math. She's
against all of that stuff. We should be better at
math. We also shouldn't be teaching creationism
in science class. And, you know, she goes to the
South Koreans are bred to be good at math. It is
widely studied that there are a number of Asian
cultures that focus on and emphasize scholastic
excellence among their young. When schools are
when well-funded and well-supported and teachers
are appropriately paid and they can, that allows
the attraction of better teachers to the job
they're against all of the staff breed. You know,
it's like she's going eugenics where what you
need to do is you need to fund education. And
it's the similar sort of thing where, you know,
some of these folks, they they like to talk about,
you know what, actually, I don't even need to give
other examples. These these really stand on their
own. She's almost got it. Why aren't we creating
an environment in which students are better at
math? Well, a lot of it is not about genetics.
It's about her movement saying do all of these
things, which weakens education. And and it's.
It's frustrating to see that she's so close,
but the narrow world view won't let her realize,
Oh, wait, maybe like all the stuff I say about
defunding public schools isn't going to get
us to what we need. I don't know that she's
ready to deal with that, but she's of the
mindset of we've got a problem. Let's use
eugenics to fix it. We don't have to wait that
long. We can fix it right now with education.